Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hello Walter.
Hi.
How are you doing?
I'm fine.
Good.
Yes. Are we continuing with
understanding Pope Francis?
That is the plan. Because if we
understand what all this is about, then
maybe we can start making sense of
what's happening in the world.
Correct. And there is obviously some
more to come as well. This won't be the
final one. Well, it's a very big topic
definitely
because it's bringing together
decades,
centuries, millennia of planning.
Yes.
And it's coming to fruition.
So, we need to understand what is going
on. And today we're going to look at
understanding Pope Francis, the Vatican
2 Pope.
And that should supply some answers to
the conservative Catholics as well and
hopefully open some eyes. Let's open
with
may God help us.
Yes. Our heavenly father, thank you so
much again for h giving us the
opportunity to have this discussion. We
ask that you bless the discussion and
also the viewers and enlighten our minds
that we can discern what to do in Jesus
name. Amen.
Amen.
Now last time we spoke about the source
of inspiration
and we showed that it was from the
exercises of Lyola
and that it was a contemplative
mode of action. So
the source is not scripture and that's
very important. But if you masquerade as
a Christian organization
but place these other uh areas in the
forefront
then you can get away with many many
things and it seems as if it's somehow
connected to Christianity but in actual
fact it's rooted elsewhere.
Yes, that's the danger of all this. It's
sometimes a lot of these things seem at
the outside if it's right.
Yes. So, let's just make sure that we
are on the right track here and that
Pope Francis indeed is a Vatican 2 pope.
So, we will go back to that interview
with the head of the Jesuit order, the
Jesuit general,
and then we'll hear what he has to say.
Um, sticking with uh Pope Francis, um
there's a narrative around him and his
papacy that he's um a radical reformer
and among his fans uh this can sometimes
lead to disappointment if they think
he's not changing things um fast enough
or or far going far enough. and among
his critics who are worried that um you
know he might be doing radical changes
that that um go against the you know the
church tradition. Um so I'm wondering uh
what do you think of that narrative and
is there is it the right one? Does it
get something wrong about Pope Francis
and what he's trying to do um to the
with the church?
Oh, Pope Francis is without doubt a man
of the second Vatican council.
For sure.
You are young people and you don't maybe
you don't remember Vatican council. But
if somebody wants to understand Pope
Francis
and his way of proceeding and his
leaderships needs to go back to the
experience to the decrees and to the
development of the church provoked by
the second Vatican council. That's a a a
reference points that we cannot
forget if we want to understand what is
going on in the church and in the in the
mind and the heart of Pope Francis. So
Pope Francis is leading the church in
the sense of Vatican 2 decided with the
adjustments needed by the new times and
the signs of the spirit. That's why he
is all the time talking about human
migration in all its forms. The
environment crisis, the grow of
inequality
because the Vatican council
teach us to read the signs of times and
to respond them and we have to respond
with dialogue among all especially
different religious and we have to use
the dialogue as the path to fraternity.
That's what Pope Francis is trying to
do.
Well, Martin, that was pretty clear.
We have it right out of the horse's
mouth
that Pope Francis is a Vatican 2 pope
that is essential in order to create
this brotherhood of inclusivity not
separateness
and uh so we have to understand it in
that context. Now the question is is
this something new? No, of course not.
This has come a long long way
and uh Vatican 2 was in 1962 already.
So we are dealing with a Vatican 2
agenda and we need to understand what
that entails.
Yes.
So let's briefly go back to the history
of Vatican 2. Vatican 2 was started
under the papacy of Pope John the 23.
He's the Vatican 2 Pope.
And this is what it was about. On 25th
January 1959,
only two months after his election as
Pope, John the 23rd, surprised the world
by announcing the council to give the
church the possibility to contribute
more efficaciously to the solution of
the problems of the modern age.
The joyful echo brought about its
announcement as well as the lively
interest on the part of non-atholics and
even non-Christians
proved in the most eloquent manner that
the historical importance of the event
has not escaped anyone.
It was what they called a renewal.
But the question is, was it?
Not only was it called a renewal,
apparently when asked what it was about,
he went to the window and opened it and
he said, "A breath of fresh air." M
now these are important issues that we
need to understand
because when it comes to the gathering
of all humanities
all systems whether political or
religious
then you need this openness
with an agenda.
Yes. Because a lot of people say Rome
has changed.
Rome has never changed. It cannot
change.
John the 23rd in Maistra
wrote, "By far the most notable evidence
of the social teaching and action which
the church has set forth through the
centuries undoubtedly is the very
distinguished encyclical letter Rum
Novarum
issued 70 years ago. The norms and
recommendation contained therein are so
momentous that their memory will never
fall into oblivion.
So now we're not dealing with a modern
pope anymore. We are dealing with a
couple of decades of history. Right?
Because if Vatican 2 was announced in
1959,
that's uh 60 years ago.
Yes.
Right. 62 years ago to be exact. The
other thing is of course he's referring
to Raram Novarum which deals with social
issues that goes back another 70 years.
So we're dealing with more than a
century of preparation here. And this is
what people need to understand.
Yes.
Never does it change. It only expands
what is already
there. actually widens the net to catch
more.
Widens the net.
In Sumat theologica, Thomas Ainus wrote,
this is one of the papal encyclicals,
because the goods of some are due to
others by natural law, there is no sin
if the poor take the goods of their
neighbors.
Thomas wrote, "In cases of need, all
things are common property." so that
there would seem to be no sin in taking
another's property for need has made it
common.
Now that statement in itself
tells us what the social climate must be
like. Now when we think of the riots
that occurred in just the last year
Mhm.
and the year before that
and some of the issues in the cities and
the Black Lives Matter movement and all
of the riots and the looting.
Yes.
And there was no recourse
for anyone that was looted. They just
have to accept it. Well, this is based
on this philosophy that the poor have
come to the point where they now have
the right without sinning to take
because it is common.
It it's actually amazing that it's
directly opposing the 10th commandment.
Yes. And the commandment, thou shalt not
steal.
So there are two commandments there that
are being transgressed.
and this man is a saint. So it seems to
me that if you are a transgressor of
God's law, you can become a saint in
Roman Catholicism.
What's also noteworthy is that this
might seem to people just a quote by
some unknown person to them. But this is
what's being planned and implemented
right through the world. I mean Thomas
Ainus is a very prominent figure in
Catholic church history and all the
papal encyclicals
refer to him. The entire idea of natural
law is largely based on the ideas of
Thomas Ainus and we will see in later um
episodes that this is very important and
uh these are papal quotes where they
quote him.
Here is another uh papal encyclical
godium its best. These are all Vatican 2
encyclicals. The Vatican 2 constitution
that John Paul 2 quoted explained at
greater length. If one is in extreme
necessity, he has the right to procure
for himself what he needs out of the
riches of others. Since there are so
many people prostrate with hunger in the
world, this sacred council urges all
both individuals and governments to
remember the aphorism of the fathers.
Feed the man dying of hunger because if
you have not fed him, you have killed
him.
So this is where Catholic social
teaching comes to the four and since the
world is so steeped in poverty in many
many areas of the world. This is a very
fertile ground to ferment unrest
in the world.
Yes. Exactly. And we can see it in our
current day.
Correct.
You see this right around.
So how do you want to further your
agenda? You need masses.
Yes.
So it is interesting to me that if you
go to the Catholic countries in the
world, that is where we where where you
find the most poverty. Why do you think
they all want to run away from those
countries and seek a better life
elsewhere? Right?
Yeah.
That's why we have all the border issues
and all of these things. So these are
very interesting things. And Vatican 2
has a social agenda. Mhm.
It has a moral agenda.
It has a religious agenda. And we need
to look at all of them.
So now the first Vatican council,
the Council of Trent, that council was
run by the Jesuits as well. Now the
Council of Trent and the first Vatican
Council was called
into existence because of the crisis of
dealing with Protestantism
and Protestantism had clearly expounded
the errors of the papacy
and Protestantism claimed solar
scriptura.
Yes. And Protestantism
put it very clearly that Christ was the
head of the church and not a human being
such as the pope and that one couldn't
have forgiveness of sins through a
system you had to go to Christ. So those
were the issues. Righteousness by faith
was a very important issue.
uh papal succession, apostolic
succession was a very important issue
because the papacy claimed
that the authority came down an unbroken
line from Peter to the present pope.
Yes. And like we've seen that's not the
case in one of our previous ones.
Correct. So now we're not going to deal
with the Council of Trent in any way,
but the Council of Trent
set the groundwork
for the separation between Protestantism
and Catholicism.
And the papal encyclicals and the papal
decrees that came out of Vatican 1
roundly condemned Protestantism in all
its forms and all its specific
doctrines.
And those decrees are excedra
from the papal chair. They are
infallible.
We will show this later on as well.
and therefore they can never be changed.
Yeah.
So Vatican 1 seems like a
anti-protestant
ultraconservative
Catholic traditionbased
council.
That's why you have so many Catholics
today who are totally confused by
Vatican 2 because it seems as if there
is such a liberal agenda.
And how does this liberal agenda gel
with this conservative traditional
agenda of Vatican 1?
So the Protestants saying Rome must have
changed.
Yes. And that's not the case.
That is not the case.
Now there's a difference
between a pope speaking excided
from the papal chair because in this
council the first Vatican council the
pope as traditionally was still carried
on the shoulders
into like the old pagan priests were
into the council. The modern council
dispensed with all of that and made him
more congenial and more acceptable to
humanity.
And many of the statements that come out
of Vatican 2 are not necessarily
excited.
So they don't contradict, they just seem
to contradict. And that's very
important. So let's look at some of
these issues because this is important.
So the question is did the Vatican 2
council change the Roman Catholic
position established at the Council of
Trent which clearly condemned all forms
of Protestantism and their doctrines.
Well, let's go to the source.
Yes,
this is the congregation for the
doctrine of faith responses to some
questions regarding certain aspects of
the doctrine on the church.
First question, the source comes from
vatican.va. This is the official
position of the Roman Catholic Church on
its web page.
First question, did the second Vatican
Council change the Catholic doctrine on
the church?
Response: The Second Vatican Council
neither changed nor intended to change
the doctrine. That's pretty clear, isn't
it, Martin?
undoubtedly rather it developed,
deepened and more fully explained it.
This was exactly what John the 23rd said
at the beginning of the council. This is
the second Vatican council.
Paul V 6th affirmed it because Pope John
the 23rd died while the council was
still in session. Okay? And so Pope Paul
V 6th, the next pope was also a Vatican
2 pope. In fact, every pope since John
the 23rd has been a Vatican 2 pope.
Nothing has changed.
Correct. Nothing. Paul V 6 affirmed it
and com commented in the act of
promulgating the constitution
luminantium.
So this is what Pope Paul V 6 wrote a
very important document which again
relies largely on previous documents.
Right?
So these things go back centuries.
There's no better comment to make than
to say that this promulgation really
changes nothing of the traditional
doctrine. What Christ will we also will.
What was still is what the church has
taught down through the centuries. We
also teach. In simple terms, that which
was assumed is now explicit.
That which was uncertain is now
clarified.
That which was meditated upon,
discussed, and sometimes argued over is
now put together in one clear
formulation.
Has Rome changed?
Not at all. Instead, it cleared up
misconceptions about the old one.
So, our Roman Catholic conservative web
pages that lament the fact that Vatican
1 seems to have been brushed aside,
really don't understand what is going on
here.
Yeah,
they don't understand the agenda.
So, we have to look at this very
clearly. Let's go to Vatican 2 and see
what we can glean.
So the Jesuits
as in the first Vatican council were
also the architects of the second
Vatican council.
And one of the most prominent priests,
Roman Catholic, Jesuit priests of the
second Vatican council was Carl Rana.
And here we have a picture
of another person sitting right next to
him. And there was already a change
here. They didn't wear their official
robes.
They were dressed and in suits and ties.
So two progressivist certain type
priests at Vatican 2. Father Joseph
Ratzinger
was a co-worker with Father Carl Rana at
the council.
So both of them were Vatican 2
individuals.
As you know, Ratzinger of course became
Yes.
Pope Benedict.
So he was also a Vatican 2 pope, but he
played the conservative drum.
And now we have a pope that is playing
the liberal drum. And this is a very
clever move because after Paul V 6th,
then we had Pope John Paul I.
He only lasted 33 days. Then came Pope
John Paul II, a Vatican 2 pope. And the
church was was feeling the heat, right?
And so we have
a pope in between who plays the
conservative drum a little more than the
liberal drum. And then we move back to
the agenda with Pope Francis.
Now let's have a look what the motto
was. Rano's motto was effectively our
Lord must conform to the world not it to
him.
These are all Roman Catholic sources.
Yeah. It's not quoted from some obscure
site.
No.
Rana's influence was enormous. He
satisfied a modern world and modern
churchmen whose ears were itching for
doctrinal compromises under the pretext
of enlightenment.
That's an interesting quote. So let's
read a little bit more about Kalana.
Galrana is undoubtedly the most
important Roman Catholic theologian in
the 20th century. His seinal position
amongst his contemporaries results to
some extent from his ability to put
theology and philosophy into dialogue.
Now there we have a problem already.
Philosophy and biblical truth are as far
removed from each other as the east is
from the west.
So Greek philosophy cannot be mingled
with biblical truth because biblical
truth is not a philosophy.
No,
it's a fact.
Exactly. It's a word of God.
And you cannot put them into dialogue
because that is called synretatism.
Exactly.
So Carl Rana originated a new religious
category anonymous Christianity.
Now if your your net is so wide that you
can incorporate any kind of fish then
why do you need a filter right you just
absorb everything whether atheist
yes
or occultist or so-called Christian or
so-called any other world religion
y
doesn't matter right
so they they're actually all Christians
but they don't know it based on the
philosophy
correct
saying it embraced Buddhists, various
other non-Christians and even atheists
who are conscientious, upright and
caring. That's all it all takes. Just
have to be a good person and that's
fine.
Some kind of faith in God is basically
there whether they know it or not said
Rana. They are a part of a Christianity
that does not call itself Christianity.
pagans who have received grace
but are not aware of it.
Very interesting philosophy.
So you can actually leave them where
they are. You don't have to evangelize
them.
Correct. Here's an article, an extract
from a a German magazine. And basically
what it says is that this individual was
the one who opened the door for the
reunification
of the Christian world
so that the Christians of the Protestant
world and the Catholic world could
unite.
So this is the the way in which this
philosophy made it possible.
Let's look at some of his quotes.
But I think that the spirituality of
Ignatius himself which one learned
through the practice of prayer and
religious formation
was more significant to me than all the
learned philosophy and theology inside
and outside of the order.
In other words, let's just get this
quite straight. Is in harmony with our
first lecture.
Correct. The basis of your spirituality
comes from the spiritual exercises and
the formation you receive via those in
the Jesuit order.
Yes,
it's more important than the philosophy
and more important than theology. So,
forget about the Bible,
forget about everything else. That which
you experience,
yes,
is the norm.
That's so dangerous. That is a very
dangerous precept because it totally
negates the biblical view of test the
spirits.
Correct? And it also becomes dangerous
when you try and Christianize this.
You cannot
even if you try and do this with the
Bible and instead know there's a lot of
danger in this like we said in the first
one. That's why you can have so many
Christian mystics these days
doing their thing.
So in his studies, Rana also became
thoroughly conversant with the thinking
of the fathers of the church especially
on the topics such as grace, the
sacraments, spirituality
and mysticism.
So these were actually mystics.
They were no longer theologians.
This is a mingling of mysticism, occult
practices
and Christianity.
So here is a web page called
ignitianspirituality.com
and it states the following. Krana
Society of Jesus Jesuit one of the most
important theologians of the 20th
century. Carl Rana was born in March
1904.
He was the fourth of seven children, the
son of a local college professor and a
devout Christian mother. In 1922, Carl
followed his older brother Hugo and
entered the Jesuit community. As a
Jesuit novice, Ra was formed in the
spiritual exercises of Sign Nazius
Lyola. This formation had a lasting
influence on his spiritual and
intellectual development.
So here we have it again from the Jesuit
web page directly.
Correct. So the basis as with Pope
Francis of the entire Vatican 2 movement
was the spiritual exercises.
Yes.
Now Martin
if you can introduce
the spiritual exercises in a modified
form
into the Protestant churches.
Yes. Then you will destroy them in terms
of their basis on the word of God.
From the inside.
Yes.
You don't even have to attack from
outside.
Correct. Then the spirit becomes the
norm and the word becomes secondary.
Correct. And then also if the spiritual
exercises were the base of Vatican 2
then obviously because the Jesuits were
in charge of the council of Trent
Vatican 1 that was the basis then as
well.
Correct. Now there are stories about his
private life which we won't go into but
there's an article by John Venari Carl
Rana's girlfriend and there are some
interesting quotes in that. He says,
"The London Times wrote of Renza Cole
Rana's girlfriend at her death. She
remained a practicing Roman Catholic to
the end of her days, but campaigned for
abortion and against celibacy as well
against as against the power of the
priesthood. In spite of that, she
counted amongst her personal friends
Cardinal Joseph Ratzinger. She stood for
the German presidency in 1984 at the age
of 73 as a Green Party candidate and
campaigned in the West for North Korean
dictator King Tusung.
Now I put that in because it's very
interesting that the philosophies
that we read there are so prominent in
the world today.
Yeah.
The abortion issue.
Correct. the whole issue of bringing in
socialism and the the the mode of
thinking
uniting communism to the west through
the glue which is socialism.
Yes.
So you have the egalian dialectic right
thesis anti-thesis
and then the synthesis. So this is where
they were moving to. So they had to have
room for these ultra liberal ideas.
So how do you bring them together? You
have to create some form of compromise
that incorporates them all.
You mentioned now you put this in
because it's so relevant today. Yeah.
Well, this she was a Green Party
candidate as well. Got the whole climate
in there as well.
So everything started in the Vatican 2
era. This whole green movement is not
something that has happened now because
suddenly there's climate change. This
has been planned for a long time. Great.
So, Rana the radical Rana himself showed
a similar maverick strain remaining
deeply rooted in his own version of
Catholicism.
He undermined perennial Catholic truth
at every turn.
Or so it seemed. Yes.
Unlike the great father Dennis F whose
mot was the world must conform to our
lord
not he to it. Rana's motto was
effectively our lord must conform to the
world not it to him. Now Martin do we
see that in the modern world?
Yes definitely
right. I mean a conservative Christian
is appalled at what is happening in the
world today
but it has gone so far that you dare not
raise your voice even to a whimper
because that would be hate speech.
Yes. And it will go against the relative
thought.
Ah
yeah
you think of it in one way but that's
your paradigm. Yes,
I can think of it differently. There's
no right or wrong answer.
So this issue of tolerance
can only be brought about
when the crisis and the conflict has
become so great
that it is unbearable.
Then you are willing to incorporate it
for the sake of peace.
You stay your gender, I'll stay my
gender. If I want to change my gender,
then you must say that is your personal
decision and I will accept it and we can
both do everything together if we
develop this absolute tolerance.
Question.
That was just an example. Yes, I wasn't
choosing sides.
No, I understand. But uh is it possible
if you go back to the Bible
that two systems diametrically opposed
to each other, one in harmony with what
God says and one in disharmony with what
God says can actually sit at the same
table?
Is it possible?
I'm asking you.
Yes,
it's possible. Is it right?
No. Because the Bible tells us you
cannot be unequally yolked.
Ah so when you start walking
with them and then you stand for a
moment with them to listen to their
point of view and eventually sit down at
the same table then your goose is
cooked. Right.
Yeah. You're in a trouble.
All right. How far will this go? because
you have to incorporate all.
Now this book, no other name, a critical
survey of Christian attitudes toward
world religions was written by another
Jesuit, Paul Neta.
And Paul Neta was a student of Kolanas.
Okay.
All right. So this is how it works. And
here is the picture of him when he was
younger. And here is the picture of him
when he was older.
So Paul Netto served as a divine word
missionary before assuming a position at
Zavia University
where he is presently professor of
theology. He received his lentiate in
theology from the prontipical Gregorian
university and he studied under kalana.
All right. Now before earning a
doctorate in theology from the
department of Protestant theology at the
University of Marborg you have to now
marry Protestantism
and Catholicism
and then once you've achieved that you
have to incorporate all other religions.
So for the past 15 years his main
interest has been Christian dialogue
with other religions especially those of
the east. His previous publications
include towards a Protestant theology of
religions.
Now the very name tells you what the
content is going to be.
And uh if you have studied it, you will
see that he answers it perfectly. You
can be whatever you like. You don't have
to be saved in the name of Jesus Christ
alone. Many many paths. And then of
course in his later time he was very
interested in Buddhism and other
religions and he wrote
Paul Neta the Paul Tilik professor of
theology world religion and culture at
Union theological seminary in the city
of New York is a leading theologian of
religious pluralism and interreligious
dialogue. Neta is author of more than a
dozen books most recently without Buddha
I could not be a Christian.
Neta's journey into interfaith dialogue
began in 1964.
So this is Vatican 2.
Correct. This is the theology that comes
out of Vatican 2 when he was a
seminarian in Rome and experienced the
second Vatican council firsthand at a
time when the Roman Catholic Church
declared its new attitude towards other
religions.
Uh is the devil divided?
No. But he appears so divided. Right?
And it also brings to mind this is
directly opposing
revelation that says come out of her.
Absolutely.
This is saying don't just stay there and
we'll just gather you where you are.
We are dealing with a clash of minds
here.
There are two totally incompatible
mindsets.
Yes. And like you said, this is the
mindset of Vatican 2.
Okay. Now, if you just think about
Buddhism.
Buddhism is the exact antithesis
to Christianity. It's the exact
opposite. It's like yin-yang.
Christ says he has come to fill us.
Buddhism
encourages you to empty yourself.
So it's the exact opposite.
The ultimate state that you can achieve
in Buddhism is the state of nothingness.
And that is the opposite of the Bible.
The state of fullness.
Yes.
So it's amazing. And this spiritual
exercises of Layola is also about
emptying and receiving then because
whatever comes to your mind you must
receive. We will see that in a moment.
Very dangerous philosophy.
So when John the 23rd died, Pope Paul V
6 became the next pope in the Vatican 2
scenario. And here is his encyclical
laopum progressio.
And this is the encyclical written by
Pope Paul the 6 on the topic of the
development of peoples and that the
economy of the world should serve
mankind and not just the few. It was
released on March 26, 1967.
Martin, is that the same agenda as Pope
Francis has?
Yes,
exactly the same. Mhm.
So is he an ultramodern pope or is he
just the same as the previous one?
Same as the previous one.
Nothing has changed.
He also wrote in that encyclical towards
an effective world authority. Does Pope
Francis ask for an effective world
authority?
Yes. A new world order.
Correct.
So he wrote here, Pope Paul 6 wrote,
"Such an international collaboration
among the nations of the world certainly
calls for institutions that will
promote, coordinate, and direct it until
a new jeridical order is firmly
established and fully ratified.
We give willing and wholehearted support
to those public organizations that have
already joined in promoting the
development of nations. And we ardently
hope that they will enjoy ever growing
authority.
As we told the United Nations General
Assembly in New York, your vocation is
to bring not just some people but all
people together as brothers.
Does Pope Francis speak about
fraternity?
Yes. Fraternity is the whole encyclical
that he wrote about.
Correct. Is it something new? No, who
can fail to see the need and importance
of thus gradually coming to the
establishment of a world authority
capable of taking effective action on
jeridical and political planes. Now
Martin this was in 1967.
Are we there?
Yes.
Correct. We are. So does Pope Francis
contradict any of the previous
encyclicals?
No.
No. He's only enforcing them.
Yes.
So we need to understand Catholic social
teaching
because the world is so
conflicted at the moment
and you have this massive divide between
the rich and the poor
which I believe is planned.
Yes. and has been
correct
quite a time.
And the the sheer numbers of those that
are feeling uh oppress
Yeah.
is leading to the very chaos that we
have in the world today. And those
people that see the picture are to be
intimidated into accepting this new
social order. So now let's have a look
at Catholic social teaching. This comes
from their web pages directly.
So you need an authentic development.
Authentic development involves a search
for a humanism. Let's just stop there.
Humanism basically excludes God
altogether.
Yes.
Because humanism puts man at the center
and man decides what the direction of of
morality or whatever issue will be and
not God.
Yeah. So to humanism totally excludes
God. So search for a humanism which will
enable everyone to find themselves a new
by embracing the higher values of love
and friendship of prayer and
contemplation.
Do you hear anything about the word?
No.
Authentic development is for each and
all the transition from less human
conditions to those which are more
human.
Yeah. And who determines the more human?
Humans.
The humans.
Yeah.
And which humans in particular? The pup.
Martin, this is excuse me
so ridiculous
that one can only shake the head. So
what they're talking about less human
and more human is the way in which you
live.
And that's why salvation
is defined as living a human life.
Salvation is not something that you find
in Christ. It is something that you find
by coming out of the social quagmire
that you are in into a better state.
Let's give you a universal income.
Correct?
Then you won't be poor.
And those that are so super rich that
have lived in luxury all their lives
need to come down a couple of notches so
we can all be one,
equally poor.
Correct. So this comes out of Pope Paul
V 6 uh popularum progressio and it's
exactly the same tune.
Yes. played on the same musical
instrument that Pope Francis is using.
The nature of authentic development is
such that all the nations of the world
must participate
for example through fair trade
relationships and international
cooperation or it will not be true
development.
So if some nations are more prosperous
than others
by the nature of their economy and their
work ethic,
then they will have to come down a notch
in order to make the others come up a
notch.
Yes.
And of course common good.
This also comes from Ma Iistra, mother
and teacher of the church. The common
good is the complete development of all
people of the world. John the 23
describes it as the sum total of
conditions of social living whereby
persons are enabled more fully and
readily to achieve their own perfection.
Now if you read that is that biblical?
No.
It's as far removed from the Bible as
the east is from the west. Right.
Yeah.
Christian perfection
is found in Christ.
Correct. Here you find it in your social
environment.
So the common good also provides a
balance against too strong an
individualism.
Isn't that interesting?
Yes. 1965 it was written this and Pope
Francis saying exactly the same.
So is he a modern pope bringing in
change or is he just applying that which
is already decided?
Yes.
Okay.
100%. So ind individualism will have to
go by emphasizing the social aspect of
the human person.
If your individualism allows you to rise
above others, then it will have to go.
It's a virus. Yeah. It's interesting if
you remember the first one. Jesuits
have are given a period where they are
demoted.
Correct. And that's to get this
so that they have this mindset. Yes.
Authentic development is possible only
if an individual interacts with and
grows within society. In other words, he
may not exceed what society is about.
Thus each of us is required to work for
the common good which includes all
others within society. Even property of
its nature also has a social aspect
which is based on the law of the common
purpose of goods. Therefore Martin you
possess
nothing. Did the world economic forum
say that?
What? Definitely. And that's their
agenda. So is there agenda that some
people are appalled at and are willing
to go onto the barricades? Is that a new
agenda thought up by Klaus Schwab?
No.
Or is it an old agenda?
Old.
Okay.
Distributism.
Interesting word, right?
Distributism is based on the notion that
power follows property combined with a
genuine love of freedom and a desire to
spread the benefits of freedom and
economic initiatives as widely as
possible.
Seen from the point of view of Catholic
social teaching. It is a real response
to John Paul's call for a change of
lifestyle,
of models of production and consumption,
and of the established structures of
power which today govern societies.
Is this the same tune that Francis is
singing?
100%.
100% right.
Economic justice.
Economics should be governed by justice
not simply by the laws of the
marketplace. Increasingly
the le's affair attitude of market
centered economics is being challenged
by the idea that there is intrinsic to
all human activities an element of
responsibility to the wider community.
So you you're not an island.
Now it's interesting Martin that that is
also a Christian principle. M
Am I my brother's keeper?
Yes.
But this benevolence
that springs out of a relationship with
God that you care for others is
something that is instilled by God into
you.
Correct?
In this system, it is something that is
instilled to you by law.
Correct?
Therefore, it is coercion.
Yes. It doesn't come from self.
It doesn't come from the right source.
It comes from a different source. The
earliest and most striking argument for
economic justice in the modern times
came from the encyclical Rum Novarum.
We're always going back to that.
Yeah.
Where Leo
the 13th argued that wages were not to
be decided by what employers or
employers could get away with under the
working of the market. Instead of a
merely economic wage, a worker had a
right to be paid a just wage.
This would be negotiated by free
collective bargaining, but should allow
a worker to live in reasonable comfort.
John the 23
developed these ideas further in materra
mother and teacher saying that the
church is called in truth justice and
love to cooperate in building with all
men and women an authentic communion.
In this way economic growth will not be
limited to satisfying men's needs but it
will also promote their dignity.
So there is this move that consumerism
needs to be curtailed.
Yes.
Do we see that in the web pages today
and in the newspaper?
Yes. There's a big movement and there's
a call by the European Sunday Alliance
to get this in the European Union
implemented.
Now you know the world is living in
excess.
That is a fact.
and maybe they allowed the excess
in order to create the problem. I found
it interesting that the German
government at one stage was speaking now
during the lockdowns and saying we don't
need all of these cheeses.
Yes,
you need one or two and that's it. Be
satisfied with what you have.
Yes,
we're living too luxuriously.
Yeah. When the lockdown um lockdowns
came, they decided what is a necessity.
Correct.
But Martin, if you follow the Bible,
then you will develop
lifestyles
that have temperance built into them.
Yes. And then it comes from a source
which is not directed by the
marketplace.
And this question of wage, this issue of
equality,
is that an issue in the world today?
hectic.
And then there's a social agenda. In his
preface to the social agenda, Cardinal
Fontuan, who was president of the
Pontipical Council for Justice and Peace
when it was published in 2000, made this
statement about the value of Catholic
social teaching, the social teaching of
that remarkable series of popes since
Leo I 13th. Now that was the pope of Rum
Novarum. So that's where it started,
right? Can be for the Christian of our
time a great source of orientation and a
general instrument of evangelization. We
all need this teaching.
Martin,
do you need the teaching that you have
the right to take from others without
asking them? No. Do you need a teaching
where you have the right to take from
others to supply the needs of third
parties without asking them?
Yeah.
In other words, if a thief enters your
home and you happen to have three
televisions in your home, he can take
two.
Mhm.
One for himself and one for his friend
who also doesn't have one.
Yeah.
And that is his right. It's not stealing
because you are living in excess and
they are living in poverty. Right.
Correct.
Now, is that biblical?
No. And it was also romanticized
by Robin Hood.
Correct. Now, I'm always interested in
this Robin Hood scenario because uh that
basically went against uh Protestant and
Protestant world, right? And uh it's
interesting that his name was Hood,
which in English means that he's an
infidel. Okay. Yes. He and some made a
little joke and called him rubbing hood.
Yeah.
So the demands of justice and peace have
an application to all levels of human
life whether individual, global or in
the context of the society in which we
live.
Pas the 11th strongly linked this theme
of Catholic social teaching with the
common good and the dignity of the human
person. Recognizing that the provisions
of the necessary means for each member
of society to flourish is the best way
to ensure development of that society as
a whole. Martin, have you heard one iota
of redemptive theology?
No. No. This is all
humanism.
Humanism.
So the only redemption which Catholicism
offers humanity
is a social structure.
Yes.
Now Martin, that is building your
kingdom on this world.
Correct.
On this earth. But the Lord Jesus said,
"My kingdom is not of this world. It is
as far removed from this world as the
east is from the west." And it spills
over into Protestantism as well.
Exactly.
Because so many people are looking for a
worldly savior and a kingdom that will
be built on earth. And can you believe
it, Martin, that there are churches that
come together to discuss these issues,
social doctrines,
ecological issues, sustainable
development, climate issues, which are
devoid of any spirituality.
Yes.
Now, you said they spill over into the
Protestant world, right?
Well, Robert Schuler
said, "The church's problem is that it
had a God centered theology for
centuries when it needs a manensed one."
Is this philosophy in the Protestant
world?
100%.
And this man
is a big name.
He's a very big man. Who was his mentor?
Do you know?
Um,
let me help you. It was Norman Vincent
Peele.
Okay.
Norman Vincent Peele, 33 degree
Freemason.
Yes. And he
I was in the Masonic Lodge and I took
his picture signed by him as a 33 degree
Freemason. Right.
Uh is there a modern president that also
had Norman Vincent Peele as his mentor?
Yes.
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump. You see how it all links
together?
Yes. I find this very interesting. Now
my question is where did he get this
idea from? And of course it comes from
Vatican 2.
At the conclusion of Vatican 2, Pope
Paul V 6 told the bishops that their
church had decided to opt for man to
serve man to help him build his home on
this earth.
Man with his ideas and his aims, man
with his hopes and his fears, man in his
difficulties and sufferings. That was
the centerpiece of the church's
interest, said the pontiff to the
bishops.
This comes from Malachi Martin, keys of
this blood.
Now my question is, with this kind of
philosophy,
can you unite all of humanity?
Yes.
Yes, you can.
But you have to rob the true Christian
of Christ.
Yes.
And you have to convince him that his
kingdom is on earth.
Correct.
Now, that is Catholicism at its best
because Catholicism
teaches a millennialism.
In other words, there's not going to be
a millennium. The church is going to
rule. And when these social issues are
implemented in the world, then the
church will indeed rule.
Yes. But it will be the kingdom of
darkness. Correct.
Richard McBryan
wrote, "The mission of the church is one
of service to the people, especially the
poor, the oppressed, and the
marginalized. Although structures of
authority are necessary for this
mission, those structures are always
subordinate to it and are to be judged
by their capacity to enable the church
to fulfill the mission.
In other words, what he's saying is that
it is man centered in its totality.
Everything has to be subservient to that
idea. And this is where we are in the
world today.
From the feminist comes the view that
the church as an Exodus community called
to abandon the established social order
and its religious agents of sacralizing
and to witness an alternative social
order. That's the agenda, a new social
order.
Yes. And we see this in all the articles
that we've shown and
and we've arrived at that point in
history. So this is nothing to do with a
changed Roman Catholic Church. It has
nothing to do with a changed doctrine
and it is now time to implement it. So
what does this tell you?
If the time has come to implement it,
then surely
they have changed the mindset of
Protestantism enough
to be able to deal with the few
dissenters that will remain.
Exactly. The pope, we had an article a
while back said that the common good has
become global.
has become global.
So they they're ready for it.
Who is going to array himself against
this philosophy?
only those that are Bible based.
Correct.
So, is there a clash of minds coming?
Oh, definitely.
Absolutely.
Like you just said,
so many have already joined this that
those that are going to stand will be in
the minority.
Correct. And then you just deal with
them like a cancer.
Yes.
The cancer of individual, this virus
will have to inoculate against it.
Correct.
We'll have to remove it. That's what
Thomas Ainus said.
Yes. And that was from before the dark
ages already.
Correct. Absolutely. So let's have a
look at Vatican 2 and the gospel
proclamation because there's no room for
the gospel. Right. H
so father McBryan labels the above ideas
as belonging to the change agent or
servant model of the church which
stresses proclamation and practice of
the gospel by application of the gospel
to the struggle for social justice,
peace and human rights.
There's the gospel of the Roman Catholic
Church. There's the gospel of the entire
world. It's not about salvation in
Christ. It's about the struggle for
social justice
on all levels. Whether it be racial or
whatever in Christ, you will be one. No
matter what social strata you come from,
no matter what background you come from,
what race you come from, you will be one
in Christ. It's a different unity and
it's a unity based on individual choice.
He writes, "The church's activities on
behalf of social justice or human rights
are not merely prepared
to the real mission of the church as the
notion of pre- evangelization had it
before Vatican 2. The church's
commitment to and involvement in the
struggle for social justice, peace and
human rights is an essential or
constitutive part of its mission. That
is the mission.
The gospel
is gone. Yeah. So now Martin, my next
question then is how did you how did
they manage to infiltrate this into
Protestantism?
You had to take away the wordbased
theology.
The theology had to move in the
direction of ignian spirituality.
And ignian spirituality is based on
experience and feeling.
Yeah.
So the whole mode of worship
had to change.
Yes.
Now how did they do that?
Well, Vatican 2 and the charismatic
movement.
Jo Cardinal Joseph Sunsets Templeton
Prize recipient in 1976 was also a
Freemason being initiated on June the
15th 1967.
This is how you reach Protestants,
right?
Because supposedly Freemasonry is a
Protestant movement,
but in actual fact it's run by the
Jesuit order.
Chosen by Pope John the 23 to be one of
the chief architects of the Vatican 2
meetings. He served on all four of its
major committees.
And he stated, "Since I've had this
charismatic experience,
my allegiance to the Holy Father as the
vicor of Christ in the world has been
heightened and strengthened. My
appreciation for Mary as the co-
redemptress and media of my salvation
has been assured. My appreciation of the
mass as the sacrifice of Christ has now
been heightened.
Let's take those points. Martin,
is that Christianity?
No,
it's totally opposite.
It's totally the opposite.
So marology, do you find that anywhere
in the Bible?
No.
No. Because Mary is asleep, right? She
knows nothing. She will be resurrected
with the saints on the last day. Uh his
devotion to the pope has been
heightened.
God in the Old Testament lamented the
fact that the Israelites wanted a king
because they rejected him as king. And
it's interesting if you look at even the
Protestant wars
in England
where England
enforced its form of government and
Protestantism on the Scots. For example,
the Scots said, "We have no king but
Jesus."
Yeah.
And uh I stand with the Scots on that
issue. So is Mary co-redemptous and
mediatorous of salvation?
No. Only Jesus.
So can the charismatic experience
lead you to a false religion?
Yes, definitely.
Right.
So Vatican 2 said this about the
charism.
It is not only through the sacraments
and church ministries that the Holy
Spirit sanctifies and leads the people
of God. He distributes special graces
amongst the faithful of every rank. The
manifestation of the spirit is given to
everyone for profit. These charismatic
gifts, whether they be the most
outstanding or the more simple and
widely diffused, are to be received with
thanksgiving and consolation,
for they are exceedingly suitable and
useful for the needs of the church.
So, Martin, when they say that you must
receive the spirit with thanksgiving, is
that biblical?
No.
Why not?
Because you must test the spirits. Ah,
because you don't know whether this
spirit is from God or from another
source.
Correct.
Because if it leads you to believe that
Mary is your redeemer or co-redeemer,
then you have a problem, right?
Yes. Exactly. So yeah, you must go back
to the standard.
And what if the spirit tells you you
don't have to keep the commandments of
God?
Yeah. Then that's if according to this,
that's what you do.
All right. So once the spirit becomes
the norm
and you accept it as the norm that means
you can accept even false doctrines.
Yes.
Okay.
So let's look at Pope John Paul II and
the charismatic renewal. So while
meeting with a number of people in 1998
already he said open yourselves dosiley
to the gifts of the spirit. Accept
gratefully and obediently the charism
which the spirit never ceases to bestow
on us. Just accept it. Is that biblical?
No. Because you have to test it.
Uhhuh.
Right. Let's see what he said further.
He said in 1998,
this comes from catholic jhbb.org.
He said, "Come Holy Spirit, come and
renew the face of the earth. Come with
your seven gifts. Come spirit of life,
spirit of communion and love. The church
and the world need you. Come Holy Spirit
and make ever more fruitful the charism
you have bestowed on us. Give new
strength and missionary zeal to these
sons and daughters of yours who have
gathered here. Open their hearts. Renew
their Christian commitment to the world.
Make them courageous messengers of the
gospel, witnesses to the risen Jesus
Christ, the redeemer and savior of man.
strengthen their love and their fidelity
to the church.
Sounds pretty good, right?
Yeah.
John Paul II has stated boldly that the
movements are the hope of the church.
Ratzinger has noted a similar
significance and has called the times we
are living in a Pentecostal hour.
So this is a movement that comes from
Vatican 2.
So let's look at an article in Zenet
which is a Roman Catholic source and it
states the following. The Holy Spirit
considered until a few years ago as the
unknown God
is the one who with his grace tirelessly
changes the lives of thousands of people
in all corners of the world.
who with renewed joy through the
experience of baptism in the spirit
begin a new life lived precisely in the
Holy Spirit.
So Basare told Zenet. So everything must
now revolve around the manifestations of
the spirit. Yes. And he's the unknown
God.
I thought he's the one that testifies
about Jesus,
but now Jesus is pushed aside and the
Holy Spirit is the one that takes the
prominent position with no reference to
the word of God.
Correct? And all of this goes back to
the spiritual exercises. Correct?
Because your spiritual exercises has to
do with your feelings, your smell, the
listening and all this feelings that you
have. This is nothing other
than a modified form of the spiritual
exercises of Lyola because whatever the
spirit implanted in him, that's what he
accepted.
Yes.
But where does that spirit come from?
Now listen to this, Martin. This is
fascinating.
He is the one we wish to honor and
glorify publicly.
Responding to the appeal that both John
Paul II as well as Benedict I 16th made
to CCR and the whole church to spread
the culture of Pentecost and the actions
of the Holy Spirit in the life of the
church and in each of the faithful.
Now, Martin, is that biblical that we
should honor and glorify the Holy Spirit
publicly or did the Bible tell us that
he came to glorify Christ?
Correct.
Christ is the one who is glorified. When
he comes, he will testify of me, said
Jesus.
He will not speak of his own. He will
lead you to the plan of salvation. This
is a new religion, Martin
and it comes out of the second Vatican
council. Correct. It is totally new.
So this celebration which will include
moments of prayer,
listening,
witness and invocation of the spirit
will end with a celebration of prayer. a
music concert and dance which will be
presented as prayer by artists of
different countries. Martin when you
look at that that is Lyola's exercises
to the tea
because you are first praying
listening
witness the invocation of the spirit and
then you end again
with a prayer and normally those prayers
are repetitive prayers
and the Bible warns against that.
So Martin as you saw they linked it
there this contemplative
activity to music.
So music plays a very important role. So
let's just go to the Vatican 2
documents. This is Vatican 2 documents
page 83.
So in the section on music in the
liturgy we read in order that the
faithful may actively participate more
willingly and with greater benefit. It
is fitting that the format of the
celebration and the degree of
participation it should be varied as
much as possible
depending on the nature of the
congregation present. So if you have a
young
jivy congregation let it go right let it
rip. If they're more conservative be a
little bit careful. But music is the way
in which we will change the world.
Correct?
Comes from Vatican 2. Prior to Vatican
2, Christian churches were places where
you had Bible reading, where you had
sermons, where you had hymns of praise
and a close. Basically, that was what
happened in the Protestant churches.
This kind of activity came after Vatican
2.
Then the liturgy. Now, what is the
liturgy, Martin? The liturgy
is everything that happens in a church
service
that has nothing to do with preaching.
Correct. The
steps.
Correct.
So in Roman Catholicism, the liturgy
takes first place. The procedure.
Yes.
Not the word. In Protestantism, the word
takes first place. So in this way, you
create a show. Correct.
It's a stage show.
Mhm.
This is Jesuit theater at its best. It
is entertainment.
Correct. And it's directed at your
senses.
At your senses. All five of them. As
Lyola stated.
So it is a sign under which the
scattered children of God may be
gathered together until there is one
fold and one shepherd.
Now Martin that means that the papacy
will be totally in control.
So you need a musical celebration
and you need a most effective style of
celebration is when music is involved.
So more recent heritage of sacred music
you must introduce popular religious
songs playing of the organ or of other
instrument characteristic of a
particular people. very gently that they
brought this in.
Didn't Rick Warren also say that your
church has to accommodate the community
where it is?
Exactly. So many of the charismatic
churches that developed after Vatican 2
are based on the music music culture of
of the area.
So some of them are country and
westernbased, some of them are pop
culture, some of them are hard rock.
Yes.
Etc. Some are heavy metal.
So the participation of the celebration
should be internal
but must be external also that is as to
show the internal participation by
gestures, bodily attitudes,
acclamations, responses and singing. So
everything had to become more lively.
And if you go to the Catechism of the
Catholic Church in article 1157, they
say song and music fulfill their
function as signs in a manner all the
more significant when they are more
closely connected with the liturggical
action. So not with the sermons, right?
This is an experience. This is the show
according to three principal criteria.
beauty expressive of prayer, the
unanimous participation of the assembly
at the designated moments and the solemn
character of the celebration. In this
way, they participate in the purpose of
the liturgal words and actions, the
glory of God and sanctification of the
faithful. And then notice how they bring
in the emotion.
How I wept deeply moved by your hymns.
Songs and voices that echoed through the
church. What emotion I experienced in
them. This is the catechism.
So we shift from a mindorientated
religion together with emotion
to a emotiondriven
religion. Yes, that's important what
you've just said. It's not to exclude
this.
No,
but it's been turned on its head.
He's the master of reversal. Let us look
how far this has gone. Uh if we look at
a modern rave concert. Is it possible to
bring that same structure into the
church?
I'm sure it is.
You've been in that world.
It is. And I've been involved in both of
the these uh a worldly rave and a
Christian festival.
Now Bon, weren't you a DJ?
Yes.
You were a DJ. You played this kind of
stuff.
Yes.
And what did it do to you?
Well, it's emotionally high. It keeps
you in a emotionally high state.
And at the the raves, you enhance that
feeling by partaking in drugs, right?
Yes. And eventually you don't even have
to take any substances
because your body has become so
accustomed to this music
so that the music by itself will create
the same
your serotonian releases from itself.
Your um energy levels kick in and you're
you can go on for hours without even
taking anything. That's how you get used
to it. Now Martin, if you come from that
religious system, and you obviously do,
don't you find the one that you are in
now boring in comparison?
Well, at the beginning it was a
nightmare.
Yeah.
I said the first thing that I would want
to change the music.
You wanted to change the music.
Yes. And as you spiritually spiritually
grow, then you start realizing, wow, no,
this you don't want to have any of this
other music infiltrating the
You want to tell me that you did 180
degree turn?
No, definitely.
180 degrees. Exact opposite of what you
were before.
Yes.
And it took quite some adjusting.
It's hard. It's not It's It's
Music is like a drug.
It's like a drug.
Well, let's have a look at this rave
concert. I hope it it's not too long,
right? I don't want to be
turbocharged here. Let's have a look.
[Music]
So Martin, we saw what happened in that.
And it's interesting. We're not going to
do a music video now, but those rhythms
are basically ancient voodoo rhythms.
Mhm.
And they create a condition so that a
low, a lesser god can take possession of
you. That's basically
spirit possession.
Correct.
And to put it succinctly, it's demon
position.
There's an excellent series called
distraction dilemma. That series really
helped me to make my final decision on
on music and it was done by Christian
Bardell. I'm
I watched that series as well
and it it is really a must for everybody
that listens to music even radio music.
I will put a link to that little series
in this.
So now we'll take that rave culture and
we'll transport it into the Christian
world and we'll look at
Well, this is a video by Hilong.
So this is Christian basically rave.
Let's look at it.
[Music]
So my question to you is, has Vatican 2
been successful?
Definitely.
Is uh Pope Francis out of line or is he
doing his job?
He's doing his job. He's implementing
exactly what they've been planning for
years.
All right, let's just make sure before
we wrap this up.
Here is the spokesman review
and it's dealing with a time in 1997
when John Paul was uh active and it says
tonight Pope John Paul II will give his
blessing to rock and roll.
The pope and a retinue of cardinals and
bishops will attend a church sponsored
concert that will feature American folk
rock icon Bob Dylan. The occasion is the
23rd World Eukaristic Con Congress being
held in northern Italian city of
Bologna.
The church is evidently hoping that it
can use rock and roll as a medium to
reach a larger audience of young people.
This plan of reaching a larger audience
of young people is implemented in all
churches. They don't want to lose the
youth. So they thinking of all this
worldly ways of keeping them in the
church.
Every denomination on the planet, it is
a very sad state of affairs. But let's
continue. The Pope's idea is to get
closer to young people through pop
music, which unfortunately for many
years has been viewed with suspicion and
indifference by the church, said Monsor
Dominico
Sigalini, a spokesman for the
Eucharistic Congress. See how
unfortunate it is that we didn't use
this medium in the past. We don't have
to read it all, but this is what it's
all about. Now let's look at this
nudging his 80s pope goes pop with an
ABA sidi. So he's showing the trend and
the young people loved it.
I remember in one of your lectures in
total onslaught there was a video that
you showed where Pope uh Paul John Paul
II arrived at a rock concert.
Well it was basically like a rock
concert. It was a meeting to honor him.
Oh,
and they were singing all kinds of music
and there was loud music and uh you know
rock bands were playing and they still
said, "How do you feel about this?" They
asked this one priest, "How do you feel
about all this loud music?" And they
said, "This is wonderful. This is what
we need." etc., etc.
So, now let's jump to Pope Francis Wake
Up. Here's an article from 2015. As Pope
Francis debuts a rock song, really, we
explore 500 years of papal tunes. The
rift began in the 1960s
when the second Vatican council convened
penning a series of sweeping documents
that precipitated a sea change in Roman
Catholic doctrine. Many of the reforms
were initiated with an eye towards
making the church more accessible and
modern. Consequently, Catholic
liturggical music began to show the
influence of pop and folk rock. To some,
it rang the death nail for traditional
and contemporary classical music in the
church. And it led to the rise of the
pop-minded pope album. Or is it the
pope-minded pop album? Wake Up follows
in the synth and stringladen tradition
of Pope John Paul II's 1999
devotional album Aba Partar and in 2009
recording by Pope Benedict I 16's alma
ma music from the Vatican.
Martin, this is an agenda well planned,
well executed.
Do you agree? They've been very
successful and they have used music to
destroy the heart of Christianity.
Yes. And it stemmed from the spiritual
exercises of Lyola. It is spiritual
exercises at its best because you're
creating the atmosphere
for this spirit engagement. Do you know
Martin, if you go into a casino,
there's a certain drone
music that is playing in the background.
It is to switch off your mind so that
you will not be able to control your
actions through your cognitive thinking.
They are the masters of this because
they like you said it comes from Jesuit
theater as well. They actually use all
of that also to switch off the mind.
So let's just go to the spirit of
prophecy.
There's something peculiarly sacred in
the human voice. Its harmony and its
subdued and heaven inspired pathos
exceeds every musical instrument.
Vocal music is one of God's gift to men.
An instrument that cannot be surpassed
or equaled when God's love abounds in
the soul. Singing with the spirit and
the understanding also
is a great addition to devotional
services in the house of God. how this
gift has been debased.
And Martin, this was written in the
1800s.
When sanctified and refined, it would
accomplish great good in breaking down
the barriers of prejudice andhearted
unbelief
and would be the means of converting
souls. It is not enough to understand
the rudiments of singing but with the
understanding with the knowledge must be
such a connection with heaven that
angels can sing through us. Isn't that
beautiful?
Now at that rave concert Christian rave
concert the Bible must be as far removed
from your mind as the east is from the
west.
You see that's the problem. you think
you while you ex while you're
experiencing
this wonderful feeling with goosebumps
all over this is the way it should be.
It's so dangerous. I'm glad that uh
you've come out of that experience.
Let's just look at a few verses here and
we'll wrap it up. Matthew 22:37.
Jesus said unto him, "Thou shalt love
the Lord thy God and with with all thy
heart and with all thy soul and with all
thy mind."
This is the basic summary of love to
God. Right?
And your heart is involved.
Your soul that is your whole being,
the whole person is involved and your
mind must be involved. If you separate
any of these elements, you're in
trouble. That's how you worship God.
Correct?
Let's just make sure. Psalms 47 6 and 8.
Sing praises to God. Sing praises. Sing
praises unto our king. Sing praises for
God is the king of all the earth. Sing
praises
with understanding.
God reignth over the heathen. God sitth
upon the throne of his holiness. You
cannot divorce the emotion
from the cognitive. They have to be
together. Let's just make sure.
And they have to be in harmony with the
Bible.
They have to be in harmony. 1
Corinthians 14:15. What is it then? I
will pray with the spirit and I will
pray with the understanding also. Not
whatever
I shall receive. No, I must pray with
the understanding and I will sing with
the spirit and I will sing with the
understanding also. God is not against
emotion.
Yeah.
He didn't create you with the capacity
not to cry.
Yeah.
He created you with the cap capacity to
cry, to be sad, to be happy, to be
joyful, to have all of those
experiences.
But once those experiences
override your understanding in your
mind, then you are in trouble.
Yes, that's the important thing. Once
it's been turned on its head,
correct?
You have to realize if you got and it's
easy if you compare it to what you read
in the Bible, you will realize it is not
in harmony.
And there are so many examples. How many
people say when they are on the verge of
or actually going into adultery
say this feeling that I have
is so good it must be from God.
That's exactly how it is.
That's how it is. Right. This feeling is
so good it must be from God. And then
you commit adultery and you break the
law of God. Was it from God or was it
from the devil? No, definitely from the
devil. So with that in mind,
let us just
contemplate what Vatican 2 was all
about, what the papal agenda is, what
Pope Francis is actually doing, and how
the whole world is being swept into this
net. And may God preserve his people
from being trapped in that net. Let's
pray.
Heavenly Father, this world is a very
dangerous place
and we have a very very sly
evil
spirit that controls the minds of men.
Help us Lord to be steeped in your word
and to accept no spirit but that which
is in harmony with your word in Jesus'
name. Amen.
Amen.
Thank you for watching this video. To
subscribe to our channel, click here. To
get notifications, click on the bell. To
watch the next video, click here. Thank
you and we'll see you again.